at this hour our democracy is under  unprecedented assault  unlike anything we've seen in modern  times  an assault on the citadel of liberty  the capitol itself  an assault on the people's  representatives  and the capitol hill police sworn to  protect them  and the public servants who work  at the heart of our republic  an assault on the rule of law  like few times we've ever seen it  an assault on the most sacred of  american undertakings  the doing of the people's business  let me be very clear the scenes of chaos  at the capitol  do not reflect a true america  do not represent who we are  what we're seeing are a small number of  extremists  dedicated to lawlessness this is not  dissent  it's disorder it's chaos  it borders on sedition and it must  end now  i call on this mob to pull back and  allow the work of democracy to go  forward